[Music]
for a second I thought I was about to
watch roughly which I would greatly
prefer also the filmmakers back in 2002
thought it would be a good idea to name
their movie after the commonly known
symbol for hardcore sex or when your
team runs out of guesses and family feud
removing your disguise at the scene of
the crime 3 shoulda left it on tickets
drive down this alley rather than
running right the Scout was able to walk
into the secret Rammstein concert
without paying or giving the secret
password just too big of yet suffering
the five that is you can do how she's in
there a point where you just lose a guy
in the middle of a concert even if this
is the brightest lit venue I've ever
seen for a metal concert in my life I'd
lose most assholes I'm chasing steak
James Bond's corpse isn't literally
getting blood on the hands of the crowd
this whooshing deep down and into a new
location seems a lot less badass when
you think of it as the wins POV budget
touched at the NSA I mean they can't fix
the elevator doors to slide all the way
into the walls a 1999 oh is that related
to the Ray Liotta keep your Sutherland
doctor movie called article 99 I'm
pretty sure this gangs name is equally
forgettable best and brightest the
bottom of barrel has a scum of the earth
and they're programmable bendable and
they work hmm I guess the movie xxx was
sort of the Suicide Squad before Suicide
Squad also isn't it the first time
they're trying this how the fuck could
he know that they work in case you
confused it with Sacramento Minnesota
that anyone who owns a car like that
would ever put a bumper sticker on it
also this comically large bumper sticker
this guy put on his expensive sports car
tells you everything you need to know
about his character
oops no wait it's the license plate vote
for dick no wait it's the gold-digging
girlfriend where were you coming from
Tijuana oh wait it's the impatient
coated racism I don't want the pain to
fade Jesus if he is not worried about
the paint then why the fuck is there a
giant bumper sticker on the back
director Rob Cohen and actor Vin Diesel
got some fast and furious in there xxx
velocity dick dick Hotchkiss a
California state senator he's the guy
that tried to ban rock music because we
deals with the lyrics promote violence
and I stole in this car which I'm going
to jump off a bridge because I feel like
I'll be able to change his voting habit
somehow even though the insurance and
the fact that he's a wealthy state
senator will easily replace this car
he's also the guy that wants to pull
every video game up every shelf of the
country he's going to have a hard time
doing that considering he's only a state
senator also the main character of this
movie is
hardcore pandering asshole I like rap
music and skateboards and video games
and I will fight for you white males age
13 to 24 watching this movie is the
footage we're seeing the footage these
cameras are actually shooting or is this
what it was like to watch videos like
this on the internet back in 2002 yes
you're a bad man
you know we did about nine elected yet
you've just entered the Xander zone
that's also what Xander tells himself
before he masturbates she's cops formed
a roadblock at the end of the bridge but
decided a ramp in the middle of the road
could just stay there because there's no
way that'll be used for anything after
30 seconds of admittedly slow-motion
falling this car is only halfway down I
think you guys are abusing your
slow-motion privileges moral is don't
for your dirt jerk
haha his name is dick and he's a dick
haha Sanders xxx tattoo is not on his
neck hopefully he didn't leave it in the
car I think the rule for movies is if
you ride motorcycles and you're sort of
a lone wolf character it is required
your apartment has one of these
elevators with the sliding cages on the
Ian Ghost Writer are roomies I think for
the scene I'm just going to add a sin
for every single time somebody says
something they think is cool lingo and
oh okay man why also for a dude that
doesn't like dicks
Xander sure hangs out with a lot of them
you know an athlete like you should
really have his own video game video
game companies are so high on licensing
wanted men these days I mean who could
forget that classic thanks he gave it
was all the rage oh no one they made for
Bernie Madoff called Ponzi crush look I
just need you to lay low to the Heat's
off okay I got an underground web site
in one each character and her haircut
inspiring ugh Julian Assange I guess
we'll never know I'm untouchable
ironic retort in three two right on time
Cindy soul is known for his action films
deep voice ripped body and Dungeons &
Dragons fandom but what he should be
known for is his beautiful eyelashes in
this scenario they dreamed up for Xander
the waitress knew there was a robbery
before the two guys even pulled their
guns out to rob the place and of course
as we're about to find out the scenario
is way too easy to defend it's like they
got this movie screenwriter to plan the
fake robbery I was a bit groggy before
then I started noticing things I hate to
admit it but as Xander goes through all
the mistakes these people made and
coming up with a realistic scenario it's
clear he'd be amazing at cinema since
reading the Financial Times on a Sunday
morning when the markets closed hey wait
I thought you said he's not a fellow but
only I fell out would know that see I
can be observant too and know
cents but their performances were
terrible that's good it's very good as
opposed to these performances which are
excellent Italy is determined to get its
hundred bucks worth out of a fake tattoo
you guys have sent them in diners
rightly our diner finalist everybody on
this plane did the diner test did they
all beat up the fake robbers because
that is a ton of abuse for those actors
to go through the play on a stupid
scenario like that or did several actors
take turns playing the robbers and the
government just happens to have like 20
expendable people on their payroll who
can get beat up in a fantasy robbery I
live with this getting kidnapped by the
government oh this is Columbia okay bad
so you hear people speaking Spanish and
you see cocaine so must be Colombia yes
I sell this sir I would like to know why
the government decided to throw these
guys into the real world of drug cartels
without giving them one detail and
hoping that would work exams are just
set the record in 13 minutes of screen
time for getting not the couch it
wouldn't be a Vin Diesel movie if you
work force to be shackled and hanging
from something also why are the two guys
who ran sitting in relative comfort
while XXX has to hang from the rafters
well they went all out on wrestling huh
does they even really think this is
still a desk I might have to get this
movie credit for inspiring Tropic
Thunder are they laughing because they
think it's actually Danny Trejo just two
seconds ago you told us to talk now it's
shut up I mean in effect you haven't
worth it is torture
holy I just realized that cinemasins is
Xander cage and for that I'm sorry
I think Matt Besler smells like real
blood good god this movie set up Xander
to be smarter than the average asshole
and he's only now beginning to realize
this might be real I think this is why
he's never tie someone up like this with
their legs still mobile I'll never
understand movie tortures how is it you
mean there with a large bag of cocaine
just lying around in the torture barn of
course the only viable vehicle Xander
finds is the one that fits his lifestyle
sander Lux out with the Colombian army
shoot around the target philosophy even
though his motorcycle was clearly
leveling out right here the wide shot
disagrees with all the previous physics
and decides you know what he shot a
hundred feet into the air
not just 32
what and despite having to maneuver his
way around barbed wire and he sticks the
landing apparently there's nothing you
can't do when you're on a motorcycle the
next thing we'll see is him flying up to
the army helicopter and somehow
attaching a bomb like he did in Furious
7 after avoiding this helicopter by
weaving around the entire compound
apparently there is just no other option
than to jump over this barn as it gets
bombed looks like the flames are
touching possibly engulfing in here but
he'll manage to leave this unscathed and
now Xander will slide into the most
convenient pipe ever created perfectly
located for a jump over an exploding
barn and big enough to fit him and his
motorcycle so you can hide the Colombian
Army has moving in excuse me it was my
idea Daniel as a decoy and liked the
idea as a decoy for what
what exactly did putting Xander and the
other two dudes in danger accomplish
that wouldn't happened anyway decoy
suggests they needed him to do this in
order to attract attention but the
Colombian army was already moving in so
what was accomplished other than the
excuse of having a rad action scene the
job's not that difficult it's not while
the agent deaths then maybe I ought to
call yourself chip black every rolled
credits yet we haven't I saw is Anders
neck tattoos so many times I just
assumed we had in case you confused it
for Parag Mozambique also I guess even
the anti James Bond movie have to find a
way to get its hero in Prague somehow
it's where all the secret agent goes
down I'm sorry did I miss the part in
film studies that explains why the Dutch
angle makes a terrible movie better I
think this movie is made with 56% Dutch
angles but it's hard to believe anyone
thought they were making art with this
movie either longing one so much my loan
I guess this expression loses something
in the chick to English translation
probably sounds really badass I'm not
stupid in Czech - I've never been under
anyone's jurisdiction samuel l jackson
just blackmailed you with the threat of
prison time so going to have to disagree
hey guys I'm America New York you're
here
argue a guy to talk to about cars how in
the world is barging in going to get
this guy's respect or work I guess this
whole movies theme is if you're totally
unconventional and don't even think
about it you'll succeed in this world
where the implants burns drink through
flashing his badge to have to bar the
bad guy never thinks to himself dad this
guy traveled a great distance just to
see me when he Luck's out by finding a
cop flashing his badge at a bar known
for being run by criminals and we've had
to kill a string of secret agents lately
because of my operation oh well I'll
make a deal with this guy and trust him
why not and this is movie back in 2002
and all the years after that but I'm
going to go ahead and predict that Asia
Argento is an undercover agent and that
our
is the director of Suspiria Ferrari I
had pasta rocket Sessler
that feels like a flirt now the business
is finished with parking basis calm
bitches oh they're gaggle of bitches
just waiting to be sent to this room
I don't remember sander passing by any
bitches when he barged in here if there
are bitches on the main floor they
couldn't have heard this guy in a loud
Club from up here I'm just shocked they
have party bitches ready to go to a
moment's notice is all she was given a
specific list of cars to go after who
told you alternate lists the cars on
that list suck it would have seen right
through it is there anybody in this
government outfit that knows how to sell
an undercover story how the hell'd you
get all this Kolya Yogi's younger
brother happens to be an action sports
fanatic we kill a bottle of vodka and
three fridge and you're going to talk
too much so this guy told you everything
about all the guys in the operation and
you just sat there and entered it into a
laptop or wrote it in a notebook or
memorized it for later
I imagine the scene was in the script
but you guys decided not to film it
because of how unbelievable it is this
one made my career so the thinking for
this character was xxx need to cube
but he needs to be as annoying as
possible every little boy's dream the
penetrator mode you know for those
peeping tom james moms out there also is
her skeleton getting him excited I am
unsure of the sturdiness of old factory
windows in Prague but this seems
excessive even by Buster Keaton
standards so from the perspective of
these Czech criminals xxx is now a Robin
Hood style car thief with a profitable
series of underground extreme sports
films who also merged police officer
even though everybody suspected Zander
being a secret agent and several known
agents have died trying to stop this
gang nobody checked to see if this cop
is really dead why do you do that to
yourself that figure is gonna kill you
one day setting up an ironic death by
the henchmen if I could I smoked in my
sleep I will still do it after it kills
me yeah well you're dead so why not I'm
guessing once you're dead the risks go
way down a thousand people at the party
and only two other people waiting at the
bar you're gay should give up his life
of crime and focus on party planning
because that's impressive how long was
she waiting on that bedpost for him to
walk in also these candles don't set the
mood in any way I'm either worried the
mansion is going to burn down or that
I've joined a vampire cult
either way my boner is going to retreat
somewhere further down the Maslow's
hierarchy of needs pyramid also did she
light all those candles herself there's
there's some kind of prostitute henchmen
who gets stuck with the
work you're not supposed to win here in
the giant room where they held a party a
few hours earlier and is also like us a
makeshift library very sorry we didn't
get to see the Ferris Bueller's Day Off
style shenanigans with the maitre d when
they tried to book a table in that
restaurant dressed like that he is
waiting off hunt with this rifle are you
telling me this guy couldn't get a clean
shot through the window I mean move a
little to the left
Jesus the son just happens to be in the
perfect position for Xander to blind
this guy with a metal trick treat
morning skate train also how in the fuck
does this guy even have a good shot
anymore you'll notice they never show
his perspective again because there's no
way he does have a good shot anymore
said Americans can just bust in and use
a historic Opera House while it's being
used for dress rehearsals for secret
mission things like planning
extrajudicial killings it's exactly why
we have a mixed reputation around the
world they're being very rude to that
opera singer Jelena just told Zander
she's never allowed down into the
underground weapons lab but mere hours
later she's being led here at the very
moment Xander's gone Rogen is following
her everything's going according to the
screenwriters plan plan in the other lab
rats down in an underground secret
weapons facility but they passed the lab
rat stage of the illegal biological
weapons production if a head should have
finished a book dude straight now xxx
has to fight with a boner these x-rays
and oculars are way too good to be
showing him an exact hi-def picture of
everything going on behind this wall
much let's take a picture of it s oh
yeah by who got sent out to buy a bow
for the detonator except they find a
crass Closet in a mansion and think oh I
know just what to do with this let's
give a surprise to your DG tonight this
may be the densest motherfucker I've
ever seen in the movie you see the organ
behind the glass with a controller and
it doesn't occur to him oh this must be
on purpose how did he get up here and
convenient rocky ceiling is convenient
castle which already has a huge gate in
front of it also had room for a
drawbridge which looks recently
installed in order to expedite
motorcycle ramp jumps I have no doubt
this stuff was awesome but when you show
the bare minimum of what this guy is
actually jumping to and from it loses
all coolest sajo Xander who only came
back because the love of his life Yelena
was still here blows up all these cars
and possibly Elena with them wooden
undershooting
apparently that's exactly why he's here
but despite having all the leverage he
decides to talk his way to his own death
Elena somehow knew this guy was sitting
behind the store in order to make these
blind shops and ex machina the situation
in short order also how did she get here
in time Sandra was way ahead after
blowing up all those cars at the mansion
but here's Elena like time and space
don't matter I had a deep talk I can
tell
we're in the room hahahaha I'm an agent
as well what no way the secret room was
where if I told you not to jump off the
Empire State Building yeah you're right
I definitely do it
see I inspired you no no you didn't
actually Xander already said he wanted
to stay and help out the girl the new
information would have happened with or
without the bullshit about the sweeper
team or telling Xander he needed to go
home some homes and that's an order he
gives this order after getting the same
order to inspire him in a previous scene
either he actually means at this time or
he still thinks he needs to fire him
further by the way I request for this
movie to stop wasting my time
remember what I told you to kiss very
good ally a rare example of music
ruining the moment rather than enhancing
it wait these guys knew to be looking
for somebody skiing down the mountain
did they kick him out a trigger an
avalanche during his two hours in spy
school just wanted to make sure we
pointed out that Xander is out
snowboarding an avalanche right now just
in case you didn't see that with your
own eyes which are king lying to you
also starting this avalanche was perhaps
necessary but also certain death
I believe Xander is as good as the movie
says he is at doing all the stunts it
claims he can but I highly doubt he's
tested those skills against an avalanche
for cots to show this stupid stunt so
movie wants you to be enthralled with
this but your brain definitely knows
better
avalanche again please quit please quit
please quit nothing like fresh powder ah
there it is the good stuff just movies
marketing focus too much on the action
and not enough on how stamp fantastic
everyone's Cotard
why don't they kill him now who knows
these guys--it Expos guys those guys in
vague these guys Thrun whole world
implode this guy enjoys way too many
rich person comforts to want to see the
world implode both on your new world
order dude like you're doing this in an
underground bunker like an evil Kyle
Reese or something you love going to VIP
rooms and having parties and hanging out
mansions call once again people who are
totally blind X muck in a situation at
the perfect height you have to turn the
safety off
sander cage no or of everything somehow
didn't know his gun safety was on
probably so we could see Elena be a
badass for a couple seconds saying
laughs oh what a great friendship this
movie forgot to depict it's correct
seeker the son of a bitches smoking so
heat-seeking Rockets would be attracted
to something as small as a cigarette
almost like the manufacturers made these
so that those cigarettes will kill you
line could come back to office dude I
told him that cigarette were children
one day
unfortunately you reminded us of it
rather than letting us remember on our
own wood you got the manual he's got
very bad handwriting and written manual
for a car that can boost up you better
call in some air support we may need to
blow this thing out more kind of insane
is that you knew everything about the
a.m. but decided against having law
enforcement or military anywhere near
the water just in case something like
this happens then their city won't die
and the crisis will be contained
yeah wiping out 1.5 million people in
Prague seems like a thing the world will
just let go does this road go back to
the river yes it does 50 miles of the
table sovaldi and I'm sure you'll be
able to drive your car the current speed
without running into any traffic
standard shoots a goddamn harpoon in a
speeding car towards a speeding boat and
hits it dead center because your face
did that idiot queue get this shipped in
from the states or did he find an
American flag parachute in the Czech
Republic
Amazon circa 2002 was good but not that
good I don't want to say that every
missile is a phallic symbol of dominance
but these particular missiles weed me no
choice
which he steals the mix in the compound
bow in the samuel l.jackson from die
hard with a vengeance
welcome to the danger zone
Looby waste time making us think sander
is dead wait a minute sounds like sander
living I better go check it out
I know you're there and I've got you
here on satellite magnification call me
how did this thing change camera angles
you got a whole new thing to talk about
psyche I'm going to talk about it with
ice cube instead also concerning this
cell phone camera who's the wannabe
cinematographer zooming in on Gibbons
while he's talking this is a secret
government message but we will practice
chromatic filming technique my god it's
like a tramp stamp Hall of Fame mashup
the only thing missing is a dolphin
this sucks oh my god back I was in
junior high dickhead
my name is island what's your name buddy
my name is time you're both ours in
concert my crazy idea now that business
is finished we party no the time I
rocket family dog I'm going to give you
a few promotion that's not how it works
that's young how any of this works they
say most of your brain shuts down in
cryosleep
all but the primitive side yeah I'm
trying Ringo who the hell are you I'm
trying real hard to be this
[Music]
you